[موسيقى]
في منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب في منزل
انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
من بالباب عيشي في المزرعه يطيب يعرفني
بعيد وقريب اعطيكم جبنا وحليب اهلا اهلا
يا بقره اهلا يا اغلى الاصحاب هيا نسمع
صوت خوارج كي نفتح في الحال الباب
في منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب في منزل
انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
من بالباب ابيض يدفو جسمي صوف وباكل العشب
معروف هذا انا احد الضيوف اهلا بك اهلا يا
خروف اهلا يا اغلى الاصحاب هيا اسمع مامتك
كي نفتح في الحال الباب
في منزل ام فى السنجاب دق دق الباب في
منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
حسناء ولدي قرون ولدي الجد الا تدرون هل
عرفتم من اكون اهلا يا معزه اهلا اهلا يا
اغلى الاصحاب هيا نسمع صوت ثغاء كي نفتح
في الحال الباب ماء
في منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب في منزل
انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
من بالباب يكسوني ريش وافير لي جنحان ولا
اطير والسوسو ولدي الصغير اهلا يا دجاجه
اهلا اهلا يا اغلى الاصحاب هيا نسمع صوت
نقيقي كي نفتح في الحال الباب
في منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب في منزل
انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
من بالباب جسمي يهتز ويميل ريش يكسو جسم
جميل من قارئ عريض وطويل اهلا اهلا يا بطه
اهلا يا اغلى الاصحاب هيا نسمع بطبطتك كي
نفتح في الحال الباب
في منزل انثى السنجاب دقه دق الباب في
منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
شعري جميل ذيل طويل ولصيد الفئران اميل
اخرج اتجول بالليل اهلا يا قطه اهلا اهلا
يا اغلى الاصحاب هيا نسمع صوتا كي نفتح في
الحال الباب مي
او في منزل انثى السنجاب دقه دق الباب في
منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
من بالباب اعرف بصديقي الانسان ايضا انا
اوفى حيوان افتحوا قد جئت الان اهلا يا
كلب وسهلا اهلا يا اغلى الاصحاب هيا نسمع
صوت نباح كي نفتح في الحال الباب
في المنزل انثى السنجاب دقه دق الباب في
منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
[موسيقى]